[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Mitri Sirin schönen guten Abend mit mir
im Studio ist wieder Kristin später mit
dem wichtigsten vom Sport das wäre im
Viertelfinale ist komplett guten Abend
wir blicken jetzt gemeinsam auf die
Themen
Mikrochips made in Germany der
Weltmarktführer aus Taiwan will in
Dresden eine Fabrik bauen saftige
Subventionsgelder machen es möglich
wenn sich alle gegenseitig helfen in den
slowenischen flutgebieten packt jeder
mit an um die Katastrophe zu schultern
und da waren es nur noch acht bei der
Frauen WM sichern sich Kolumbien und
Frankreich die letzten Tickets für das
Viertelfinale
[Musik]
in Zeiten großer wirtschaftlicher
Unsicherheit bei uns kommt heute diese
Nachricht Taiwans Chip-Hersteller TSMC
baut ein Werk in Dresden Gesamtkosten ca
10 Milliarden Euro die Hälfte kommt als
Subvention vom Staat ähnlich groß
engagiert sich ein us-halbleiter
Fabrikant in Magdeburg umstritten ist
das beide Standorte in Ostdeutschland so
stark mit heimischen Milliarden
gefördert werden es ist aber Teil einer
größeren Strategie das Ziel das ist
ehrgeizig bis 2030 will die EU den
Anteil an der weltweiten Chip-Produktion
auf 20% hochschrauben eben um Europa
unabhängiger zu machen etwa von China
Chips ja sie sind Schmierstoff und
Gehirn moderner Technologien und damit
auch unserer Welt und ohne sie geht
nichts mehr in der Automobilindustrie in
der Unterhaltungselektronik oder eben in
der Hightech Medizin aus Dresden
Franziska wunderlich
sie sind die DNA moderne Technologien
Mikrochips das in Zukunft mehr von ihnen
in Deutschland hergestellt werden sollen
das bestätigte heute der Chiphersteller
TSMC in Dresden will der Konzern eine
neue Fabrik bauen und voraussichtlich
2027 die Produktion starten
dein großer Tag zum Jubeln vor allen
Dingen weil so viel Arbeit dahinter
steckt und weil es ein richtiger Schritt
nach vorne ist für die technologische
Souveränität der Bundesrepublik und hier
das Ökosystem Sachsen im Bereich der
mikroelektrik natürlich deutlich stärkt
mit Bosch Infineon und NXP plant das
tawanesische Unternehmen eine
Kooperation gemeinsam sollen Chips
hergestellt werden die dringend von der
Automobilindustrie benötigt werden dazu
will das Quartett mehr als 10 Milliarden
Euro in den Standort investieren mit
Hilfe der Steuerzahler denn der Bund
plant Subventionen in Höhe von 5
Milliarden Euro noch muss die
EU-Kommission zustimmen das aber gilt
als sicher
die EU entschieden mitzulaufen im
Subventionswettlauf den es gibt kann man
gut finden kann man schlecht finden aber
man ist jetzt wettbewerbsfähig auch als
Standort als Region und die Ansiedlung
montiert dafür im Wettbewerb um die Chip
Hersteller werden weltweit enorme
Förderungen aufgerufen die Politik muss
manchmal eine Wette auf die Zukunft
eingehen und das betrifft vor allem
Schlüsselindustrien Geld geben
subventionieren das alleine reicht nicht
der Staat muss eine gute Infrastruktur
bereitstellen Fachkräfte müssen da sein
die Regulierung Bürokratie muss so sein
dass Unternehmer auch investieren können
gut 2000 Arbeitsplätze sollen in Dresden
entstehen und ein klein wenig mehr
europäische Unabhängigkeit in der
Halbleiterindustrie
ja große IT-Investitionen in Deutschland
können nicht über die Tatsache
hinwegtäuschen dass unsere Wirtschaft
gerade schwächelt Valerie Haller in
Frankfurt das liegt nicht nur an
Strukturproblemen sondern unter anderem
auch an Daten wie sie heute aus China
kommen ja tatsächlich und die haben es
in sich China dem Exportweltmeister geht
die Puste aus um über 14% sind die
Ausfuhren im Juli im Vergleich zum
Vormonat eingebrochen ähnlich schwach
die Inlandsnachfrage das ist ein herber
Rückschlag der zeigt China erholt sich
wirklich nur langsam von der strikten
corona-politik seiner Regierung ohne
Anschub Hilfe vom Staat dürfte die
chinesische Konjunktur nicht wieder auf
die Beine kommen denn sie hat gleich
mehrere Schwachstellen einen
angeschlagenen Immobiliensektor hohe
Jugendarbeitslosigkeit und schwachen
Konsum China ist nach wie vor ein
wichtiger Markt für deutsche Unternehmen
das zeigt sich beispielsweise bei den
Absatzzahlen der Automobilindustrie doch
er verliert langsam an Bedeutung das
wird auch durchaus von der Politik
unterstützt viele westliche Regierungen
auch die deutsche ermuntern ihre
Unternehmen sich unabhängiger zu machen
das zeigt langsam Wirkung vom Ende des
China Booms zu sprechen wäre aber
trotzdem noch verfrüht Valerie hab
vielen Dank nach Frankfurt jetzt in die
Ukraine bei russischen Angriffen in der
Nacht sind mindestens sieben Menschen
getötet worden mehr als 80 verletzt
örtliche Behörden berichten dass im
Abstand von 40 Minuten zwei russische
Raketen in der Innenstadt von pokrowski
im donbas einschlugen neben Wohngebäuden
wurde auch ein Hotel getroffen mehr von
Nina kuscheln
katharina ist gerade am Telefon als die
erste von zwei Raketen hier in pokrowsk
einschlägt der Schock bei der
58-Jährigen ist groß die Verletzungen
sind deutlich denn die Detonation sie
war gewaltig
die Flammen schossen mir direkt in die
Augen ich fiel auf den Boden meine Augen
tun wirklich sehr weh sonst geht es mir
halbwegs gut nur noch die granatblätter
an meinem Hals aber gut
Wohngebäude Restaurants Geschäfte Cafés
Spielplätze werden getroffen auch ein
Hotel das vier von Hilfsorganisationen
und ausländischen Journalisten genutzt
wurde
wir gehen davon aus dass mehr als 160
Häuser zerstört worden sind
noch in der Nacht versuchen
Einsatzkräfte nach dem ersten Beschuss
zu helfen dann 40 Minuten später der
zweite Einschlag und dieser trifft dann
auch die Ersthelfer sowie volodia Nicoli
ja es gab Informationen dass es zu einem
zweiten Angriff kommen könnte aber als
wir dort waren mussten wir den Menschen
doch helfen ich habe die Rakete gehört
und noch versucht mich zu schützen aber
ein Granatsplitter bohrte sich durch
meinen Rücken bis in die Lunge
die Rettungsversuche mussten in der
Nacht immer wieder unterbrochen werden
zu groß die Gefahr dass noch weitere
Raketen einschlagen doch keine 24
Stunden später packen Sie schon wieder
an bauen wieder auf wir lassen uns nicht
unterkriegen sagen sie egal was da noch
kommt
das Hochwasser in Slowenien fließt
langsam ab das ware Ausmaß der Schäden
wird jetzt sichtbar neben vielen
Gebäuden sind auch wichtige
Verbindungsstraßen zerstört darunter
eine Vielzahl Brücken das berichten auch
deutsche Mitarbeiter vom Technischen
Hilfswerk die seit gestern im Land sind
bis die Unterstützung überall ankommt
dann müssen sich die Menschen vor Ort
selber helfen aus litusch im Norden des
Landes Wolf Christian Ulrich
hier war eine Straße jetzt ist hier nur
noch der Fluss das Traumhaus am Ufer
abbruchreif 240 Häuser hier in der
Gegend von letusch haben die Fluten
zerstört jetzt der Versuch Ordnung ins
Chaos zu bringen bis hier stand das
Wasser zeigt vielen leckner
das Wasser stand so hoch dass wir mit
Booten gerettet wurden das Haus ist
jetzt unbewohnbar wir haben jetzt alles
ausgeräumt
Tante Franziska bringt Stärkung
wenigstens kann ich so helfen sagt sie
und später gebe ich Geld es ist toll wie
viele Leute hier sind damit hätte ich
nicht gerechnet
die Männer mit den Schaufeln greifen
dankbar zu die Gegend um die Tusch
gehört zu denjenigen in Slowenien die am
stärksten von der Flut betroffen sind
was hier passiert ist eine echte
Katastrophe sagte Bürgermeister viele
Leute sind obdachlos unsere Priorität
ist jetzt die Stromversorgung und das
Trinkwasser wieder anzuschließen
ob punktmaschinen vom Zivilschutz oder
Unterstützung am besen was hier in
Slowenien neben der angelaufenen
internationalen Hilfe jetzt genauso
zählt die große Hilfsbereitschaft der
freiwilligen im Land alle packen mit an
ich bin nur froh dass meine Mutter
nichts passiert ist und dass meine
Verwandten hier sind um zu helfen
aus dem ganzen Land kommen hier Menschen
zusammen um mit anzupacken und
denjenigen zu helfen die es jetzt dann
notwendigsten brauchen doch auch wenn
die Hilfe groß ist manche werden nie
wieder in ihre Häuser zurückkehren
können
die Regierung hat den kommenden Montag
zum solidaritätstag erklärt alle
bekommen frei um den Flutopfern zu
helfen
auch in Nordeuropa kämpfen die Menschen
gerade mit Unwettern in Dänemark
Schweden und Norwegen gibt es
Überschwemmungen und Erdrutsche
besonders schwer traf das Unwetter die
Kleinstadt Aare in Schweden dort trat
ein Bach über die Ufer und überschwemmte
die Innenstadt die Polizei spricht von
vielen Schäden
heftige Regenfälle erschweren weiter die
Lage in Norwegen vor allem im Osten des
Landes sorgen Wassermassen für
Überschwemmungen zahlreiche Menschen
mussten in Sicherheit gebracht werden
jetzt wollen wir nach Brasilien schauen
in Belem treffen sich die
amazonas-staaten zu einem Gipfel bei dem
es um sehr viel geht auf dem Spiel steht
die Zukunft des größten
regenwaldgebietes der Welt der größte
Teil der Waldfläche der liegt in
Brasilien denn Folgen Peru Kolumbien und
sechs weitere Staaten als tropischer
regenwalter wirkt der Amazonas unter
anderem ja wie so eine natürliche
Klimaanlage für unsere gesamte Erde es
verdunsten große Mengen Wasser das kühlt
und sorgt in der Atmosphäre dafür dass
die Feuchtigkeit zirkuliert und sich
dann als Regen auch weit über den Wald
hinaus verteilt das ist ein wichtiger
kühl und feuchtigkeitskreislauf und wie
dieser einzigartige Lebensraum erhalten
aber gleichzeitig wirtschaftlich genutzt
werden kann zeigt uns jetzt Christoph
röckerath
an der Schlaufe hängt sein Leben 50
Palmen klettert Rogerio Bahia jeden Tag
auf diese Weise hoch auf der Suche nach
einer unscheinbaren Frucht
die bittere Beere ist ein
Grundnahrungsmittel im Regenwald
bedeutet viel für mich es ist das
Produkt von hier aus unserer Region dass
uns ernährt und uns ein Einkommen
sichert
immer gefragter auch außerhalb von
regiräus kleinem Dorf tief im
brasilianischen Regenwald wegen der
Vielfalt ihrer Nährstoffe gilt die Beere
als sogenanntes Superfood
und damit ist als er ihn nicht nur eine
Chance für die regionale Wirtschaft
sondern für den Regenwald insgesamt denn
am besten wächst als hi wo der Wald noch
intakt ist Profit ohne Abholzung scheint
möglich doch um assai und andere Früchte
des Waldes exportieren zu können müssen
sie getrocknet werden dafür haben Sie
Ihr eigens eine Fabrik gebaut doch bis
heute hat der Stromversorger den
Anschluss nicht gelegt beklagt der
Leiter der örtlichen kooperative
wir könnten hier zu Pflaumen Mango
Guaven und anderes Obst trocknen und
damit eine lokale Wertschöpfung mit den
Produkten aus unserer Region schaffen
die sonst schnell verderben
16 Stunden braucht die Fähre bis Gelenk
der nächsten Großstadt auch die langen
Wege sind eine Herausforderung hier
draußen
dort in belain treffen sich Experten
Regierungschefs und Anrainer zur
regenwaldkonferenz um eine gemeinsame
Strategie zu beschließen wie sich die
Abholzung des Waldes stoppen lässt und
die Menschen von und mit ihm leben
können
ganz anderes Thema jetzt von
Langzeitfolgen nach Virusinfektionen
hört man seit der Pandemie noch häufiger
dazu zählt auch eine krankhafte
Erschöpfung die sich bei jeglicher
Anstrengung verschlimmert diese schwere
neuroimmunologische Erkrankung wird
abgekürzt mecfs genannt und ist schon
länger bekannt vor Corona waren davon in
Deutschland rund 250.000 Menschen
betroffen jetzt sind es schätzungsweise
mehr als 500.000 die Krankheit ist
komplett sie ist wenig erforscht und
darauf das zeigt uns jetzt zu seiner
Santina machen Betroffene eindringlich
aufmerksam
seit Januar ist Angela Müller ins Bett
gefesselt die 48-Jährige hat er mit CFS
eine schwere neuroimmunologische
Erkrankung die bei ihr durch mehrere
Virusinfektionen ausbrach seit sechs
Monaten liegt Sie 24 Stunden am Tag im
Bett das schlimmste an der Krankheit ist
dass die Anwesenheit von anderen
Menschen mein Zustand verschlechtet wenn
ich meine eigenen Kinder nicht mehr
ertragen kann das ist das Schlimmste
jedes Medikament das sie nehme habe sie
selbst recherchiert sagt Angela ihr Mann
ist ihre große Stütze sonst ist sie
maßlos enttäuscht auch von der Politik
ich weiß dass alle wissen wie schwer die
Krankheit ist wie häufig sie ist wie
dringen Therapien sind es gab die
Anhörungen wir schreiben ja täglich an
die Politik es ist ja Sie wissen was Sie
tun
Anerkennung Versorgung und deutlich mehr
Forschungsgelder fordern sie in Berlin
kamen Betroffene und ihre Stellvertreter
zusammen denn die meisten sind zu krank
um selbst dabei zu sein auch die
Organisatorin der Aktion die 22 Stunden
am Tag ans Bett gefesselt ist da gibt es
Menschen die schlafen in der Badewanne
weil sie einfach nicht mehr schaffen in
die Küche oder sonst wohin zu kommen das
muss man doch bekannt machen das ist so
wichtig dass sie endlich Hilfe kriegen
es gibt bundesweit nur zwei
Kompetenzzentren für mrcfs das einzige
für Erwachsene in Berlin die Forschung
ist am Anfang doch man kennt inzwischen
Risikofaktoren so haben Frauen
beispielsweise ein aktiveres Immunsystem
und Frauen sind auch sehr viel häufiger
von mecfs und postkow wird betroffen wir
wissen auch dass es genetische
Risikofaktoren gibt in diesem Familien
treten dann häufiger
Autoimmunerkrankungen auf mehr als
500.000 Menschen leiden an einer kaum
erforschten Krankheit viele Betroffene
fühlen sich im Stich gelassen
jetzt zum deutschlandticket das wird 100
also 100 Tage Bus und wahrnehmen
Nahverkehr für 49 Euro im Monat und
darum ist es Zeit für eine
Zwischenbilanz die ist zwiespältig und
das war zu erwarten denn wo der Bus nur
sporadisch kommt hilft auch das günstige
Ticket nicht ganz anders ist es in den
großen Städten Martin Niesen hat sich
umgehört
volle Bahnen und Busse auch außerhalb
des Berufsverkehrs und trotz
Sommerferien in Hamburg ist das
deutschlandticket an dem wahrsten Sinne
des Wortes voller Erfolg seit Mai
verzeichnet der Hamburger
verkehrsverbunden mehr als 250.000
neukundeninnen und Kunden das ermöglicht
mir dass ich günstiger zur Arbeit komme
ich bin bei mir im
Urlaub einfach so
bundesweit verkaufte sich das 49 Euro
teure Ticket bislang mehr als 11
Millionen Mal vor allem in großen
Städten und Ballungsräumen auf dem Land
ist die Akzeptanz hingegen deutlich
geringer ich habe keinen zwei
ich sehe keinen Anschluss habe was
bräuchte es hier damit es sich lohnt
eine vernünftige Verkehrsanbindung die
nicht nur vier Mal am Tag fährt dort
müsste das Angebot ausgebaut werden
fordert der Vorsitzende der
Verkehrsministerkonferenz der Länder wir
brauchen mehr Züge mehr Verbindungen
mehr Vertaktung auch insgesamt mehr
öffentlichen Verkehr gerade auch im
ländlichen Raum
Milliardeninvestitionen in die
Infrastruktur die Bund Länder und
Kommunen zusätzlich zu den Milliarden
Subventionen für das deutschland-ticket
stemmen müssen im Herbst gehe ich davon
aus dass wir dann also eine nachtelang
Messe haben werden mit dem
Ministerpräsidenten und den
Bundeskanzler wo dann also gefragt wird
wo soll eigentlich das Geld herkommen
oder feststellen dass das 49 Euro Ticket
gar nicht seriös finanziert ist in
Hamburg stürzt sich daran erst einmal
niemand denn mit den Deutschland Ticket
lassen sich auch die elbphären Nutzen
für eine Hafenrundfahrt ohne
Zusatzkosten
wenn Sie nachschauen wollen welche
Effekte das deutschlandticket hat
Details haben wir in unserer ZDF heute
App für Sie zusammengetragen mit
Grafiken etwa zur Anzahl der Bahnfahrten
auch im Vergleich zum neuen Euro Ticket
so jetzt geht es sportlich weiter zur
Fußball-WM die letzten Tickets für das
Viertelfinale sind vergeben Christian
ziemlich zackig von 32 runter auf acht
mit einer überlegenen Vorstellung
sichern sich Frankreichs Fußballerinnen
das Weiterkommen 4:0 gegen die
Außenseiterinnen aus Marokko das
Erfolgsgeheimnis der Französinnen wir
sind ruhig geblieben und haben unser
Spiel gespielt
Frankreich findet früh seinen Rhythmus
dominiert das Geschehen
karcherui mit perfekter Flanke auf Diani
das 1:0 in der 15 Minuten nur 5 Minuten
später die ja nie diesmal als
Vorreiterin mit dem Blick für Kenza Dali
der Favorit für 2:0 und legt direkt nach
Marokkos el Chat wird von dir nie
geblockte liest du mehr als zur Stelle
3:08 23 Minuten
ein Debakel droht doch Marokko
stabilisiert sich nur noch ein Treffer
für erneut lesso mehr zum 14:0
Frankreich souveränen im Viertelfinale
trifft auf Gastgeber Australien
[Applaus]
und das am Samstag live zu sehen hier
bei uns im ZDF danach bekommt das
England mit Kolumbien zu tun dass ich
erstmalig für einen WM-Viertelfinale
qualifiziert 1:0 gegen Jamaika und alle
WM Spiele finden Sie bei uns auch kurz
gefasst online unter ZDF heute.de
nach dem gewaltsamen Tod eines
griechischen Fans von AEK Athen hat die
UEFA das für heute geplante Champions
League Qualifikationsspiel gegen Dynamo
Zagreb verschoben gestern Abend kam es
bei Athen zu schweren Krawallen nachdem
kroatische Hooligans trotz
Stadionverbots angereist waren es gab 96
Festnahmen der junge Mann sei durch
mehrere Messerstiche schwer verletzt
worden und verstarb auch FIFA Präsident
Infantino sprach sein Beileid aus es
gäbe absolut keinen Platz für Gewalt im
Fußball
und ich habe noch ein Erfolg vom
Radsport bei den Weltmeisterschaften im
schottischen Glasgow Bronze für die
deutsche mix-teamstaffel im
Mannschaftszeitfahren
es ist die erste Medaille für die
deutschen straßenradprofis bei den
Weltmeisterschaften im schottischen
Glasgow bei dem Staffelwettbewerb
Staaten zunächst drei Männer wenn der
zweitbeste von ihnen nach gut 20 km über
die Ziellinie fährt geht das frauentrio
auf die Reise die deutschen Männer legen
die viertbeste Zeit vor Deutschlands
Frauen angeführt von Ricarda Bauernfeind
vor knapp zwei Wochen wurde France
Etappen Siegerin gelingt noch die Fahrt
aufs Podium wir wussten dass die anderen
Nation natürlich stark sind aber wir
wissen auch was wir können und ja am
Ende muss man dann einfach weil es
addieren und schauen dass man schnell
ist am schnellsten ist wie im
vergangenen Jahr die Schweiz Silber geht
an Frankreich
ganz großes radsport-event geht noch bis
Sonntag schauen das war schnell sind
habe ich gelernt okay danke Christi so
allmählich geht es wieder aufwärts mit
den Temperaturen morgen tut sich die
Sonne allerdings noch ein bisschen
schwer Details gleich von Katja
horneffer wir empfehlen um 21 Uhr des
heute-journal mit Maria das lomka danke
fürs Interesse und noch einen
entspannten Abend für Sie
[Musik]
guten Abend nach einer kleinen
Regenpause heute kommt doch gleich hier
vom Ärmelkanal das nächste Regengebiet
hinterher und dieser Regen breitet sich
im Laufe der Nacht vor allen Dingen über
die Mitte Deutschlands aus und auch an
der Ostseeküste sind noch einige
Regenschauer und Gewitter unterwegs bei
einem immer noch recht starken bis
stürmischen Westwind die Temperaturen
heute Nacht sinken auf 15 Grad an der
Nordsee oder auch am Oberrhein und bis
auf 8 Grad am Alpenrand und morgen
Vormittag regnet es erstmal weiter in
der Südhälfte wird es trüb sein
Vormittag sehen sie allerdings schon in
Norddeutschland hin und wieder die Sonne
an der Ostseeküste gibt's dagegen
Regenschauer und Gewitter am Nachmittag
verziehen die sich immer mehr nach Osten
und dann kommt auch hier in
Süddeutschland häufiger die Sonne zum
Vorschein Temperaturen liegen morgen
zwischen 17 Grad an der Ostsee und 25
Grad am Oberrhein und dann wird es von
Tag zu Tag wärmer allerdings bedeutet
das nicht immer puren Sonnenschein am
Donnerstag gibt's noch einige
Regenschauer im Nord und in Südosten und
nach einem sehr sonnigen und warmen
Freitag wird das Wochenende dann wieder
etwas wechselhafter guten Abend